hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy i'm kristin disarro the chief
learning officer at khan academy and i
am excited today to talk to mike
flanagan the ceo of the mastery
transcript consortium we'll find out
what that is and what it means for
mastery learning to have such a such an
organization before we get started a
couple
khan academy is a non-profit
organization and we do rely on donors
like you to help us keep doing the work
we do if you go to khan academy.org
donate you will find a place where you
can make a contribution to help us keep
doing the work that we're doing
second we do want to thank uh some of
our supporters who have helped us with
the covenant 19 crisis response
including att general motors and fastly
next if you want to listen to other
conversations that i've had or that sal
has had with interesting guests you can
find us where you get your podcasts at
homeroom with sal the podcast
so you can tune in and listen
and with that i am excited to welcome
mike flanagan welcome
greetings delighted to be here
excellent so
i will start from the beginning you're
the the ceo of mastery transcript
consortium i bet when you were a kid
that wasn't quite what you said you
wanted to be when you grew up
what is your career trajectory event
like to bring you here
yeah that that that's true i i it would
be a really interesting kind of toddler
walking around being like i want to lead
a non-profit association of
schools um yeah i uh so i uh started my
career as an english teacher i taught at
an independent school in honolulu hawaii
uh and i taught there for three years
and it was about as cool as it sounds uh
it was really great uh and i moved from
teaching and to starting on the path of
academia and then i did a pivot and i
wound up in technology and i actually
wound up doing a bunch of startup
companies both with some college
classmates a college classmate of mine
and other friends along the way
and then things came full circle where
i've now sort of wound up in this role
that is a really interesting hybrid of
of teaching and pedagogy and schools and
technology and uh yeah it's it wasn't a
linear path uh but it's one that landed
me here and i'm i'm pretty excited about
it and i think that idea of you know
non-linear paths is actually probably a
pretty good fit for a lot of the things
we think about in terms of our schools
and the way we try and serve kids
that totally makes sense and i always
say the path my career path i can tell
the story looking backwards it makes
sense but at any given point it seems
like i was making some left turns or
some some weird shifts yeah
so it's also teacher appreciation week
this week so before we get started
talking about your your work are there
any teachers that you'd like to
recognize from your past
yeah i i grew up when i was in high
school i i was just um i loved school
right i was my happy place but i was
very much a stem kid and so
uh my high school science teacher mr
ezekiel who taught me ap chemistry
and uh gave me uh
probably started me on the road to
teaching uh when it was time for us to
get ready for the ap he broke the
textbook in different chunks and had
each of us kind of gave us
responsibility to teach one and he gave
me organic chemistry and the light bulb
went on i realized like oh i loved i was
so much more comfortable confident that
i really had owned the material because
i had to explain it to somebody else
like that sense of how do you step out
of yourself and really figure out how to
make this make sense to other people um
the light bulb really went on for me in
a lot of different ways so mr ezekiel if
you're out there thank you
awesome excellent
so let's talk mastery transcript
consortium what is that tell us what it
is and what you do
yeah so we're a non-profit and what we
really are is a collection of innovative
schools we've got a network of just
about 400 high schools mostly here in
the u.s some international and what our
schools have in common is the concept of
mastery learning and we will unpack
master learning i'm sure throughout this
discussion what it is and what it means
but really at its core it's uh it's an
embrace of real learner-centered
pedagogy and a rethinking of assessment
that's really centered on the idea which
shouldn't be radical but kind of is that
all children are capable of learning
right and it's our job as school leaders
and system leaders to create structures
and supports to make sure that they're
all doing the work and really mastering
this material at the highest level
what happens and this is where things
get interesting this is where the
transcript comes in and also the
consortium is that if you lead a really
innovative school
and you're adopting a whole bunch of the
models that we'll talk about you know
throughout this discussion
you're going to basically stop producing
a lot of the metrics that we think of as
high school
so if you're giving credit based on
mastery proficiency it's a really
important tenant of mastery learning the
basic idea is like hey
don't give credit based on the number of
hours students have been exposed to a
subject give them credit when they've
actually nailed it some students will do
it more quickly some will need more time
but once you do that you're not giving
credit based on the carnegie unit
anymore you're not giving credit based
on credit hours
when you think about the way we assess
students like it's just sort of normal
traditional grading kind of assumes that
kids will be distributed on a curve some
kids are good at school some kids are
not
um master learning rejects that
principle we basically say no all kids
are capable of learning some will learn
faster than others and that's fine
but they can all be really proficient
you know and some will even be advanced
and in that kind of model like what is a
c minus like a c minus doesn't even
exist anymore in those models so you
take those two things credit hours
traditional grades you put those kind of
on in the parking lot and then you also
take this idea of like what is school
what should kids be learning
um
and traditional transcripts really think
about classic academic subjects english
math science social studies there's
nothing wrong with those things they're
great um but there's a lot more that we
want kids to learn and be excellent at
particularly if we're going to prepare
them for a really interesting and maybe
volatile and uncertain future we want to
give them 21st century skills we wanted
to give a have opportunities to do deep
interdisciplinary learning
there's literally no place to capture
those kinds of 21st century competencies
in a traditional transcript so what you
have is this really odd phenomenon where
schools that are in some ways being the
best possible school that brain science
says you can design
is now producing kids with student
records that don't make any sense to
college because college is used to
thinking about credits grades
and the classic academic disciplines
that's a big issue um you know i'm as a
parent as an educator um i think these
schools are awesome i want as many of
them as possible to grow and kind of you
know propagate around the country i want
every kid to be able to have access to
one but if the message is oh you can go
to this really innovative school but you
might not get into college because you
look different
that's not going to be good for adoption
like so
college is not the only or most even the
most important destination but it's
definitely a blocking issue
if if we cannot show that these
innovative schools can still give kids
access to kind of higher ed campuses
that's going to be bad for us as kind of
system change agents and so that's what
the transcript is designed to do it's a
it's a translation tool um that takes
the models that our schools have and
we through our best effort presents them
to higher ed in a way that's interactive
usable and hopefully makes a lot of
sense and helps them understand sort of
where um these k-12 schools are headed
got it that makes sense so to unpack
some of that let's start with the the
pedagogy and the mastery learning piece
so part of the reason we wanted to i
wanted to talk to you is because fun
academy also really believes in that
idea of it's it's okay to fail your
first attempt it's not about what score
you get on one attempt it's about
reaching a high level of proficiency on
the skill and how you get there
um what are some of the things that you
see is uh foundational for mastery
learning and some of the key tenets
yeah well i mean there's foundational
and then there's also sort of what
becomes possible right so foundational
is definitely this idea of
um students progress when they've
mastered a particular skill and not
before and if you're going to do that
that necessitates a more personalized
approach right you can't have kids
learning at different rates and then
expect them all to you know move in
lockstep they're just you know
fundamentally it does doesn't compute
so that has implications for your school
day your school schedule uh it implies
certain kinds of technologies to kind of
reduce the administrative burden on
school leaders and faculty
but at the end of the day personalized
approach is really key
thinking about those cross-disciplinary
21st century competencies and skills
finding ways of re-centering those into
what kids do and sort of and giving
helping them understand that a lot of
things that used to be tacit in school
right like what does it mean to be a
good leader what does it mean to really
affect collaborate effectively on a team
what does it mean like to be creative or
to solve problems creatively those
aren't like intangible things they can
be taught you know you can describe to
you know a pretty high level of
precision like what good performance
looks like in those things and if you
start a process of exposing kids to
those things as early as eighth ninth
grade there's no reason why they all
can't kind of get to really high levels
of performance by the time they leave
high school as opposed to sort of
focusing on your academic subjects and
hoping they sort of pick up that stuff
along the way
um so those two things 21st century
skills that are cross-disciplinary
credit based on proficiency not seat
time those are the kind of the
essentials and then what becomes
possible is a lot of opportunities to
have kids engage in deeper more
purpose-driven learning so if you have
students if they're given more choice
right because they're on a more
personalized approach and they're not
wedded to studying the same things as
all their classmates at the same time
then there's no reason they can't do
more project-based learning do long-form
capstones or independent studies
you'll hear me use the word we a lot in
these discussions because we've got this
amazing network of schools right and
they're you know private schools public
schools districts there's rural urban
big small it's a it's amazing kind of
really heterogeneous group and that's a
good thing
but a lot of them have kids doing
project and problem based learning
either individually or in teams they're
having kids solve real world problems
not like cookbook science like you would
do like kind of in in lab where it's
like oh we're going to measure you know
drop something and see how long it takes
to fall well surprise like gravity's
constant we kind of know how long it's
going to take to fall we're going to
have them solve messy problems right
there's a reason a lot of our schools
embrace things like design thinking and
entrepreneurship it's not just because
they're hip
it's because they're cyclical they sort
of assume a certain amount of iteration
like try test iterate repeat adjust
those sorts of things
you know we think are really powerful
because they create that space to fail
in a constructive environment right to
that it's okay not to be right your
first attempt is not always going to be
your best one so those are i think are
sort of like that combination of things
that are essential to mastery learning
and things that sort of become possible
and pretty exciting and frankly more
interesting for students
you know we
talk a lot about the mission of mastery
you know transcript schools really all
schools i think is to prepare young
adults for what they want to do next
um whether it's college whether it's
career whether it's kind of something in
between
what i think is really interesting is
that for many kids in traditional
schools the hardest word in that
sentence is want what do you want to do
next we don't ask kids what they want to
do very often in traditional schools we
tell them what to do and as a result
they internalize this message that to be
a student like to be a learner is to
kind of show up and do what you're told
uh and then we launch them into the
world hopefully we want them to be
successful and it turns out that's not
the way the world works like you have to
figure out what you're going to do
specifically so
yeah that's sort of yeah
that's like the opening feels like one
of those 21st century skills is actually
learning how to learn and being an owner
of your own learning and yeah knowing
how to set goals for yourself and see
monitor if you're on track and doing all
of those kinds of things to understand
how to learn yeah i think
we
we started like phase one of mtc was
very much focused on showing that kids
could get into college without these
traditional metrics right um
and one of the reasons we've been really
successful um even with a small number
of schools that have fully adopted our
transcript we've gotten kids into 250
colleges and universities some of the
most selective and also open enrollment
two-year technical programs everything
in between
but i'm always really quick to tell
people it's not actually because of the
transcript like the transcript is not
does not give you an advantage
in getting into mit or to caltech
but going to a mastery learning based
school like one in which you're
encouraged throughout four years to like
really do deep work
like to think about it reflect on that
work with an adult in your life maybe
write something about it maybe present
it to a group
and then make a decision about what you
want to do next with that maybe it's
iterate maybe it's revise it maybe it's
going a different direction try
something new if you do that cycle
really purposefully and with a lot of
feedback and coaching
by the time you get out the other end
like your metacognitive skills what you
just said chris like learning how to
learn
they are absolutely super powered and so
when you talk to our kids our kids you
know the kids that go to these schools
they just make amazing applicants
whether they're applying for an
internship or a job or applying to
college
because they've got real
authentic answers to some of these
essential questions like what do you
want to do if we
give you a slot at this campus right
where you can do any sorts of things
major in all kinds of different subjects
and study with some of the world's best
experts what are you gonna do here what
will you do to take advantage of it if
we give you an internship at our company
um you know what what can how can you
contribute what are some things that are
interesting like why do you want to work
here versus somewhere else
they have those answers uh because it's
not the first time they've been asked
those kinds of really deep questions
about what they're doing and why and
that for me for us is that metacognitive
move learning how to learn that you
described
yeah yeah absolutely
so the
let's paint a picture then if you don't
have take a test get a grade what does
it look like to
be able to demonstrate that you have
these skills
yeah i mean i think you know our schools
still have tests right like i i don't
want to you know paint a utopian picture
where our kids like never look at
anything that looks like an exam um you
still need like academic content and
there's a place for that but i do think
that what you'll see and much more often
is much less focus on
kind of high-stakes assessment
and much more judicious use of that and
much more focus on feedback right on so
what we want to do is have students
really engaged in
real work
and then have them
giving feedback to one another teaching
them how to give feedback in a
constructive way like that's a pretty
important skill it's a life skill you
know i think we've all unfortunately had
experiences where we've worked with
people who maybe didn't have that skill
didn't know how to give constructive
feedback and like that's not like a
recipe for like awesome performance um
so helping kids you know get real
feedback both from one another and from
adults
and then you know creating really clear
structures for what they're being
assessed against so i think one of the
things that um every single one of our
schools in fact i would say like you
really you can't use the mastery
transcript or really any
competency-based transcript unless you
as a school as a learning organization
have a really really good portrait of a
graduate right and so portrait of a
graduate for us is the term of art for a
really well-designed set of competencies
and ideally what they've been they've
been created sort of in a backwards
design process right you ask yourself
the essential question of what do we
want our kids to be able to do
by the time they leave our campus right
what do we want them to be able to do by
the time they cross the stage and and
grab that diploma and so for us that
portrait of a graduate
is
really the cornerstone to that because
every single one of those competencies
in turn
should have really clear descriptions
like you know with a lot of bloom's
taxonomy language about you know what
those
demonstrated behaviors look like
um
one of the real challenges of
traditional grading is that sometimes
students don't actually really know what
they're being graded on and so i think
one of the advantages of so-called
standards-based grading right if you
look at the work that joe feldman has
done in grading for equity
it's this idea that oh these things have
to be super explicit everyone should
know on day one what good looks like and
when you see it spelled out that way you
realize how often that isn't true
sometimes in traditional grading
environments the other thing is that you
should really be assessing sort of
what it is essential to the school
environment like the learning as opposed
to things like behavior and compliance
um there's a lot of like traditional
grading models that sort of blur the
line between classroom management and
actually measuring what kids can
actually do and what they're actually
learning
and it's really important to stay we
think really squarely on one side or the
other uh and then lastly i think the um
you know so standards-based grading is
great but it is the beginning of kind of
a school evolution process true mastery
learning is
uh if you think about it as a venn
diagram standards-based grading is a
smaller circle and mastery-based
assessment is in a larger circle around
it
got it that makes sense
um so lots of questions but we do have a
question um
coming in asking about
for the average teacher who's maybe in a
traditional school but wants to begin
doing some of this
um how can they how can they bring some
of these ideas into their current
practice when maybe the system isn't
quite set up for the doing it yet yeah
and i think i really appreciate whoever
asked that question because it's really
important to take a step back and if you
say like well why do we even have or why
do we even need a mastery transcript
consortium like why not just like have
teachers start to do this
it's that the system change
is really hard
right we have to change both like our
policies in our 50 states we have to
change the technologies that our
teachers and administrators and learners
have access to
um and so one of the reasons we're a
non-profit and trying to drive system
change over time is because we know that
this is a long road like there's a lot
of work to do
and we're really glad to have so many
allies in the space right we're part of
a much larger and really vibrant
ecosystem of of non-profit players that
are all working on kind of
competency-based education and
personalized learning and and
mastery-based assessment and kind of all
pulling schools we think in a good
direction
that said if you are a teacher and you
are out on an island right you're the
only person at your school like
theoretically who is interested in
rethinking grading and assessment there
are things you can do um contract-based
grading
is a model that is
most mastery-like i think given the you
know if you are
in the confines of a traditional
classroom and a traditional schedule so
you don't have autonomy necessarily over
how long your class is going to run or
maybe even like what your kids are
studying what you can do is
on day one be really clear with students
about what the standards are for them to
achieve say a b or an a
and then work with them throughout the
year to help them understand where they
are in terms of getting it
and then giving them space
and this is a real key principle of sort
of stance-based grading and grading for
equity giving them space to retake and
retry kind of high-stakes assessments
whether they're big projects or tests um
and there's a really amazing array of
literature on that and mtc is like does
not own that space right if you go to
um you know just even on social media
there are incredible networks of
teachers self-organizing around teachers
going gradeless the ungrading movement
uh there is a real groundswell of
educators who realize like oh we've
gotten ourselves into a situation where
the thing that is supposed to
measure learning which is assessment
grading
has now kind of been a weird way looped
back where it's actually pulling and
pushing against learning and i don't
think anybody ever designed you know
wanted that to be the case like i think
we should all agree that like our
assessments should help kids learn not
push against them and i think there's
growing recognition around that a lot of
resources available
yeah yeah excellent thank you so
i know um
i'm also on the board of the con lab
school who's been one of the original
users of this and
i when i first saw that the transcript
itself was like oh this is amazing can
you share with us a little bit about
just what a transcript looks like in
yeah we and so i will just say we are
very lucky to have a very simple url
it's
mastery.org so if you want to kind of
learn more about what that transcript
looks like and see a version of it
at the core a mastery transcript is a
visualization of a school's competency
model
and we spent a lot of time before we
even built the sketched the first
transcript system
we spent a lot of time talking to higher
education
our team were really lucky we were able
to kind of sign some confidentiality
agreements and actually sit in
admissions offices and listen
as the readers were looking at actual
student folders and what you realize is
that even though the organize this the
colleges vary quite a lot there's sort
of a workflow of what they're looking
for the first question they always have
is what is this school like what is this
program like i want to understand the
context of where this applicant has done
their high school work and so
traditionally they might look at a
school profile they might then look back
at the transcript and make them
try and cross-reference so for us the
front page of the mastery transcript is
a visualization of that school's
competencies and by looking at it you
can instantly tell if we've done our job
right like what that shape of the school
is right you can see like this is where
they spend the most time we're really
big believers that students learners in
mastery based schools should develop
what we call like a jagged profile right
so if you give kids time and space to go
deep in things they really care about
they'll go in different directions
that's a good thing that's a feature
like not a bug
and so schools can have jagged profiles
as well and so we want those to
literally pop off the page
the second thing you'll look at then is
that jagged profile the competencies for
the student in particular if every
student who got the diploma earned these
over here
then individual students will go in
different directions we have a separate
section that visualizes that
we call them sort of advanced
competencies or advanced mastery credits
and so the um in that space is really
where we can start to
help colleges do what they say they want
to do which is match their applicants
based on fit to the programs they're
applying to and the campuses that
they're applying to
and so if you have students who say that
you know they're applying to a nursing
program right you're going to look for
some stem background but you're also
going to look ideally i would think for
some kind of service orientation so
that student has started to do some
things that show like yeah they really
care about other people they want to
spend their time like maybe it's
volunteer work maybe it's caring for
siblings
um but making moves choices in their
life that show that you know they've got
an orientation towards helping other
people out that's a pretty big predictor
uh whether he or she is going to be
successful in a nursing environment so i
think that's really important and so
that's and you can imagine other
examples like that you know so
um you know what
that fit between where the student has
chosen to go deep and what they say they
care about and what they want to go
deeply in college uh if you when you see
that alignment it helps you sort of uh
kind of identify that it clicks really
quickly in ways that honestly
traditional transcripts don't
one of the strange things about a
traditional schooling model is that as
students get more successful quote
unquote in school their transcripts
actually start to look really similar
they're all taking the same ap classes
or honors classes they're all getting
kind of 4.0 grades and so the thing that
is most important the thing that's
supposed to capture like four years of
high school
actually doesn't tell you much at all
about what makes them unique or
different and so that's one of the
problems that we tried to lean into
pretty hard
that totally makes sense and so what's
been the reaction from the
colleges and universities that have
gotten these transcripts
so um what i always kind of say are our
um
our reach has been limited but our
uptake has been really good and here's
what i mean um there were a million
distinct applications that got processed
through the common application last
season right so we have a lot of work in
front of us you know if we want one
uh and so if you were to go to
a any pick a random uh folder reader if
you will an admissions officer at a
campus hey have you seen a mastery
transcript statistically almost
certainly they're gonna be like nope i
have no idea what you're talking about
but for the schools that got a mastery
transcript we've got a really good track
record of getting in front of those
proactively and talking to schools
college readers
about that experience and you know it's
pretty obvious right if i call you in
the abstract and say would you like to
do a focus group about this strange
alternative transcript you're like no i
don't think so but if i call you it's
like hey by the way this is arriving
like in two
weeks it or more importantly would you
like to give us feedback when you're
done
there i think we've got a really good
sort of kind of uptake there i think it
also helps too that when we started this
work i think there were a lot of high
school excuse me college readers who
the concept of competency based or
mastery based education seemed a little
bit abstract they're like i don't know
what you're talking about and frankly
they're working in institutions that
have decades of institutional research
data and systems that use gpa and things
like sat and act to pretty good effect
at least to do what they want them to do
um nobody was asking us for change like
nobody came to us and said hey mtc can
you please give us an alternately you
know completely different way of doing
our work
um
however what's happened in the past
couple of years right well we've had a
global pandemic uh
many
institutions have gotten completely
moved away from standardized testing
because of the pandemic we've had a lot
of kids who applied to college two years
ago with pass fail transcripts from
otherwise traditional high schools
uh we've got a lot of kids who
may not have had access
to
the remote school hybrid school
offerings that their local district
schools were offering them
and so you've got a lot of folks who
previously were pretty content with like
the status quo who suddenly now are kind
of snapped to attention standardized
testing is changing the concept of
credit based on sea time is changing
if as many higher ed leaders do believe
that equity is really critical to
college admissions like understanding
that access to education has been really
inequitable during a pandemic
all of these things we think kind of
line up
in favor of us as a sector i mean that
like the k-12 sector moving towards more
mastery-based competency-based
approaches in a way that um obviously
the past two years have been horrible
like at a national level
for a pandemic i wouldn't wish that on
anybody but it definitely has changed
and accelerated the way really key
stakeholders are now thinking about a
lot of the stuff we're talking about
yeah so let's let's go to a couple of
questions from facebook rebecca says
where can you find high schools that are
using a mastery curriculum do you uh
does master.org have a list of those
where can folks look
we definitely have a list every school
that's part of the mtc membership is
listed publicly on our website
and i really want to be clear about this
we are not
there are many amazing mastery based
schools that aren't part of our network
and those schools are awesome too so
i'll give a shout out to the big picture
learning network which is a network of
amazing schools that are really
innovating uh and and really pushing
really hard on thinking about what
schooling looks like and how we serve
kids
um there are there's an organization
called the aurora institute that
publishes a map and updates it i think
updates it quarterly but definitely
several times a year uh and they show
you sort of what is the state of
competency-based education in each of
the 50 states
uh and it shows you that there are some
states that are like they're going all
in they're basically saying what we're
going to go personalize competency based
across the entire state
and it's really interesting because um
in a world in which so much of our
educational practices and discourse have
gotten really politicized
there is no correlation to the politics
of a state and its adoption of
competency-based education or
mastery-based education
it's like
it makes for strange bedfellows in a
really good way there are some folks who
are saying hey this is a key driver for
equity it's about serving communities of
kids who have been traditionally
underserved by our systems we need to do
better by those kids and there's also a
model that says
we really are focused on business we're
focused on the 21st century and being a
place where kids can graduate and get
amazing
you know technology-based manufacturing
jobs and we want to give them the skills
for that and what's really interesting
is then you wind up in the same place
they all wind up talking together about
mastery based learning which i think is
pretty great
yeah that's great and leads actually to
brian from facebook's question of what
are the challenges involved in
partnering with public schools
well it depends on the public schools so
the um the challenge and the greatest
strength and liability of our national
education system is that we have a
massively decentralized system right
sometimes that's awesome it gives re you
know districts even individual schools
in districts a lot of autonomy to
experiment we i think
we exist largely as a consortium because
there's these lighthouse districts right
led by a really inspiring you know
inspirational leader says we're going to
do things different we're not gonna wait
for permission from our state and they
need a network and so they come and join
us which is great um but then there's
also um states where you know the
policies are just not favorable like if
you are trying to transform your
district and you want to embrace credit
based on proficiency
rather than on seat time
it's not going to help if the law says
kids have to take x hours of social
studies in order to graduate you need
someone to give you permission to do
that
and so those are probably the biggest
challenges it's not challenges specific
to public schools as public schools it's
differing rates of adoption of favorable
policy frameworks in different states
and localities and again sometimes that
works in your favor sometimes there'll
be states utah south carolina there's a
lot of interest in kentucky right now
where um they'll create really favorable
policy frameworks and provide funding
and then you know it can be off to the
races
fantastic it is we are already 30
minutes in and our at con quickly
it sounds like the the work you're doing
both really unblocks one of the big
um you know concerns or objections that
folks have which is oh if we do this how
are we going to be able to get students
into college and where those is which
sounds like one of those pieces
um i'm going to end on one more question
that came from youtube nasser grunono
says
what are all those metal full medals for
so they are thank you nasa out there so
they are they are none of them is a
victory medal and i think that's really
important and hopefully on brand for
what i'm talking about like we're we're
not against we're we're we're an
anti-sorting organization they're
finishers medals for different races of
different lengths and different types
and i keep them up there because i think
they're a pretty good kind of metaphor
or analogy for grading based on mastery
if you finish even if it takes you a
little bit longer you still get that and
if you get a wide enough array of them
for different lengths and different
events it starts to tell a story of what
you can do and uh you know we so i keep
them up there as a kind of reminder of
what we're trying to do give kids
evidence that even if it takes them a
little bit longer to get to proficiency
or mastery in certain areas um as long
as they got there it's good
fantastic thanks so much for the work
you're doing and look forward to seeing
more from the mastery transcript
consortium thanks for being with us
today
thank you so much it's been a delight
excellent and to all of you we actually
have another ed talk tomorrow with
nicholas ferroni who is we're going to
talk to you specifically about what it
would look like if we really appreciated
teachers so stay tuned for that and
we'll see you tomorrow
you